Matt good morning how you feeling I'm
feeling good dan thank you for having me
on
hell's morale with the Falcons pretty
good today we played well yesterday and
you know scored some points on offense
which is good and your defense played
really well so things are good here if
your wife didn't watch the game could
she tell if you won or lost by your mood
when you came home 100% she knows when I
get in the car with her you know is a
good day or a bad day and I kind of wear
it on my sleeve a little bit about the
bad day what's that like that yeah the
bad days I'm quiet usually just you know
don't really want to talk about anything
or let the game or anything like that
usually just keeping myself in those
situations but it's one of those where
you know you guys are playing well and
my big criticism of the Falcons has
always been they relied on you too much
I wanted some more defense and you have
a running game well Vick Beasley's
playing well he'll be up for defensive
player in the year in the NFC and you
got a running attack how much pressure
does that take off you what's huge I
mean for us in terms of winning games
right I mean you have to play good
defense you have to run the ball when
you need to and we've been able to do
that this year you know I think our
defenses continue to get better as years
going on you mentioned pic Vick is
playing at a really high level right now
and I'm not sure if he's still leading
the league in facts but I mean he's
getting after the passer really well
which is fun to see in our offensive
line and running backs I've done a great
job this year so it takes a lot of
stress off our passing game in general
how do you know you've had a good game
personally it's usually a field thing
for me it's you know we've got to make
their decisions get our guys into the
right place there's a lot of checks and
audibles etc that you go through
throughout the game and those are things
that you know I always want to be a
hundred percent right on all of those
things and then you know you got to be
accurate so that's kind of the two
things that I put into you know my play
well categories make really good to say
put us in good spot to be accurate with
football he's Matt Ryan the Falcons in
first place in the NFC sounding at the
Panthers coming up if you didn't pick
Boston College what was your second
choice I always between BC and Iowa
those were my two spots
why not Iowa was further away from home
that was it
you know I could have picked we're
really like two different places PC was
really different from from Iowa City and
but you know I like both of them Kirk
Ferentz was the head coach and I really
really liked them but I chose BC because
there's a little closer to home and and
you know be easier to get to and from I
was reading where your your wife's
maiden name she's Sarah Marshall yeah so
so so the movie you guys must hear the
what is it forgetting sarah marshall
that movie that came out years ago
jason segel was in yeah yeah yeah you
guys were like I hate you Sarah money
for when I need it okay but she was a
basketball legend in the state of Maine
right yeah rape state Player of the Year
she sees an app Suzanne absolutes dead
and good player BC is as well okay if
you played can she could she beat you in
a shooting contest yes on a number of
occasions
did you get gifts do you get gifts your
offensive lineman I did okay I haven't I
haven't given them out that they're here
how to practice facility and our guys
will get them sometime this week give me
an idea though what you know what is
Matt Ryan getting his offensive lineman
I'll give you some previous year staff
previous year we've time I think last
year I think last year was drones I
think I got them drone he's really cool
like Toronto they should fly
those were those are priests we've done
TVs in the past all kinds of different
stuff electronics but this year's a
little bit different we travel a lot and
so it'll be something that has to do
with traveling then that's what that's
what those guys are going to get this
year does anybody get you anything they
keep me healthy which is that which is
different ass way Julio's not getting
anything we usually don't exchange gifts
mean who it's uh you know it's the wide
receivers they usually do stuff amongst
themselves you know you don't kiss up to
coach Quinn and get him something doing
a holiday president I never got Mike
Smith a holiday president either no
kissing out there the mentality of going
for two or plan for a time we've seen
that a couple of times solid yesterday
with the Eagles against the Ravens it if
it's your choice you can go for the tie
and play for overtime or go for two in
the moment explain that to me the the
rationale well you know I think from the
player's perspective like if you ask me
I'm gonna say of course we're gonna get
it though for two so that's just a
mindset that you have to have playing
you know but it's similar to like I
think of sometimes when I was playing
basketball growing up or in high school
or whatever we would talk about just
extending a game when you're in in
situations where you're down just keep
extending the game get to or whatever
and keep it going I think that sometimes
you know what coaches are thinking
they're just kick a field goal and we'll
play defense or get falling over time
and keep it going I'm not sure what the
stats say what the analytics are you
know but I would assume much most people
error on that side yeah I didn't know
and I'm watching the games yesterday
with Tony Dungy and he said you know
Philadelphia has nothing to play for
like the Bears had nothing to play for
and they went conservative and played
for overtime and then Aaron Rodgers made
him pay for it so I I'm figuring if
there's nothing to play for go
for the win if you get caught up in the
moment even though you had the Eagles on
the road the Bears were at home I
thought that they were gonna go for a
touchdown and try to knock out Green Bay
so I don't know like I don't know that
matters okay I agree with you I think if
I steal thing I think you have to you
know kind of feel the situation at home
on the road what they're doing how the
game is making out I think you gotta
take all those things into account well
congrats our Happy Holidays there and
hopefully somebody gets you something
Matt that'd be nice man all right thank
you Matt all right that's Matt Ryan
Falcons quarterback the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]